rylo odinga says he won't accept the
results of kenya's presidential election
he came second with 48
of the votes we have
beaten by then deputy president william
ruto with 50.7 percent
but he called the final tally a travesty
that can plunge the country into a legal
crisis
he blames the chair of the electoral
commission mafula chabukati our view in
this emilio is clear
the figures announced by mr buccati are
null and appointed
i repeat the figures and announcements
of publication are null and void and
must be crushed by a court of law
in our view
there is neither a legally and validly
declared winner not a president-elect
chaos broke out at the talling center
when some people tried to stop the
process
four out of seven commissioners walked
out in protests they say the
commission's chairman declared results
that they had not fully agreed on they
also said the total percentage of the
four presidential candidates did not add
up we concluded that
the process
that went into generation of
form 34c
which
he used to declare results of the
presidential election was opaque
and incapable of earning our ownership
and confidence
political coalition says it's compiling
a list of electoral malpractices that
went against the law rylo dinga and his
supporters say they will go to court
they have raised concerns about the
integrity of the presidential tally they
also say they have enough evidence to
support their case
members
they have seven days to file a petition
at the supreme court the judges will
then sit within 14 days to make a
decision catherine soy al jazeera
nairobi